guys in a year full of bad news it feels
like counter-strike has had
more than its fair share the majors have
been cancelled we're only playing online
and there's been a coaching scandal that
has rocked the esport to its very core
and now there's something new an
investigation alleging
widespread use and abuse of stream
sniping to cheat
at the highest level of cs go now the
question is
why hasn't anyone been punished for it
well i talked the org behind the
investigation
and the answer might be simpler than you
think
[Music]
now before we get into the story proper
i have to remind you that the score
esports is doing our
annual award show this friday december
11th it's going live on twitch and
youtube
and i want to see you there now back to
the story
last week the esports integrity
commission a watchdog group whose
mission is to
investigate and prosecute cheating in
esports
dropped a bombshell of a report and no
i'm not talking about the coaching ban
i'm talking about a new investigation
that alleges widespread cheating in the
form of stream sniping at the highest
levels of cs go
let me read you the first part of esic's
report on their own investigation
quote through the period of may to june
2020
esic received numerous allegations of
coaches and teams engaging in stream
sniping behavior
having the broadcast stream visible
during the progress of the match
usually on a second monitor sometimes
called ghosting
during online competitions since the
initial notification of this
issue to esic esic has received and
assessed
compelling evidence depicting that this
behavior
has been taking place on an alarmingly
regular basis
and at all levels of competition end
quote
and if you don't yet grasp just how big
of a problem this is
just listen to what esic commissioner
ian smith told me
about the scope of this alleged stream
sniping abuse
if we had continued the investigation
and
followed through on prosecutions beyond
the first two that we uncovered
we the very high likelihood is that we
would have had to ban
at least and i'm saying at an absolute
minimum
nine tier one counter-strike teams
that's 45 players out of tier one
plus coaches plus teams for
what for at least nine months
and some for longer that's hard to hear
and it's hard to read esic's report
it's shocking especially if you're
someone who cares about counter-strike
and it's so soon after we learned of the
widespread
and long-term abuse of the coaching
spectating bug
and this has already sent some tangible
shock waves through cs go
flashpoint fined one of their member
teams mibr
ten thousand dollars of their prize
money for having the flashpoint stream
open during one of their matches we had
a conversation about
mibr's viewing of the stream with our
board of governors and have decided on
the following action
in the flashpoint playoff match between
og and mibr
it came to our attention that mibr had
the official flashpoint stream on a
television
that the team could watch from their
playing positions while we have our
streams on a long delay to reduce the
amount of information teams can gain
from watching the broadcast
we still find mibr's action to be a
breach of a competitive integrity in our
event
we will be fining mibr ten thousand
dollars from their prize winnings and
donating it to a brazilian charity
that we will select after the conclusion
of our tournament all flashpoint teams
have been notified that any evidence of
watching the broadcast stream during
their matches will result
in disqualification and just yesterday
what we might call a kerfuffle in canada
erupted when players refused to allow
blast
unlimited access to their voice comms
and video recordings
now it was never explicitly stated but
it seems reasonable to assume
that one reason blast wants access to
all this aside from content
is to investigate and prevent future
allegations of stream sniping the
counter-strike players association
released a statement about it
and blast even addressed that live on
their broadcast during a special segment
now back to the esic investigation the
report details five recommendations for
tos
to help prevent potential stream sniping
abuse
but this time no bans no sanctions
and once you get past the initial shell
shock of this investigation
the question on a lot of people's minds
is why isn't esic
doing anything after all they handed
bands out like candy when it came to the
cs go coaching scandal that emerged
earlier this year
and apparently there's still more to
come the reasons for this as
outlined by esic in the same statement
were essentially threefold
one it would be far too damaging to the
tier one competitive scene
two it's difficult with the limited
resources they have
and three in some cases it's hard to
prove conclusively
and consistently so they chose to draw a
line in the sand
saying that no one would be prosecuted
for past offenses
but any future offenses would be quote
prosecuted vigorously
but a lot of the people looking at this
from the outside in weren't satisfied
the prevailing sentiment online in some
cases seem to be
wait a minute isn't esic supposed to be
the people who enforce the rules
the people who prosecute the cheaters
well i reached out to esic hopefully to
get a little more insight into
why they weren't able or chose not to
prosecute anyone for stream sniping
and esic commissioner ian smith the guy
you heard earlier in this video
told me that the general public simply
does not understand the scope of
resources needed
for an investigation this massive just
to give people a context of what that
means
is that in the two cases that we that we
were in the process of dealing with when
all of this came up
in order to successfully um
let's say prosecute the the two teams
that we were initially dealing with
along with help from one cs admin i had
to listen to 13
hours of team cons to get about 45
seconds worth of evidence
until somebody pays esec
and me to sit through what looked like
about 250 to 300 hours
of in team cons and video to find
whether there was a case to answer or no
case to answer
then you know happy days give me the
money i'll hire some poor kid
you can sit in a dark room listen to
in-game
comms for for two months and find those
nuggets that allow me to say this coach
this player
this team were abusing were cheating
using the stream
we either you know act fairly
and take take everybody on in in a fair
and impartial manner
for which we need massive resources that
we don't have
and and people take the hit when we ban
nine ten eleven tier one teams fifteen
twenty tier two teams and so on and so
on
in other words we chop the head off
counter-strike
or we do what we did smith said that the
esports integrity commission
from a budgetary and personnel
perspective is
simply not equipped to deal with
problems this widespread
and this deep according to him they're
underfunded
overworked and don't see a penny from
valve for their efforts
somebody expecting us to listen to 300
hours of
in team cons needs to also realize that
that needs paying for
and we don't have that kind of money
we're an organization living on about
300 000 a year doing a 3 million
a year job people need to accept that
you know and and we get nothing from
valve i'd hasten to add like not one
penny
so yeah we're doing their job for them
on an unpaid basis
now you heard him use that phrase
earlier chop off the head of counter
strike
and some people online were upset at the
decision not to prosecute
because they felt that esic might be
protecting cheaters
in fact i spoke to one cs go coach who
is currently serving an esic band
who said he thought that the lack of
action
is specifically to protect
counter-strike's top
teams and players he says compared to
the coaching scandal
it's all a double standard and because
famous and influential players and teams
are involved
that's why the investigation stopped he
did wish to remain anonymous when making
these comments
but the esic commissioner told me that
it is the practical reasons we talked
about earlier
that are the first and most significant
reasons why no bans were handed out
and that if esic had all the resources
it ever wanted
the decision to prosecute would still be
a discussion
and he didn't seem sure if it would land
one way or the other
and of course if we find a case to
answer we in general
we prosecute but i've never made an
in-principle decision of this nature
before so to that degree
we're in uncharted territory it has been
done in other sports
but to say that you know i kind of
realized that we were looking at nine
at least nine tier one counter-strike
teams and therefore i thought oh this is
too much i don't wanna
i don't wanna affect the ecosystem too
much it's part of it but it's
it wasn't the motivation the motivation
was if we're going to do this properly
we we need a hell of a lot more resource
than we currently got
i have to say from speaking with the
esic commissioner i did get painted
a bit of a different picture than what
was communicated
in their official report from talking to
smith it did become clear that esic
is simply not equipped to deal with
problems this large
and that resources are the real problem
but the statement they gave on twitter
mentions the damage to top tier cs first
and it sort of glosses over the massive
amount of resources needed
for an investigation of this scale and i
do think this is where a lot of the
reaction online comes from i don't think
people particularly
understand what a little not-for-profit
organization like esic
is really up against and honestly i
can't blame them
hell i had to talk to the commissioner
just to fully get it myself
you know we're a very very lightly
funded organization
trying to do a really really big job in
a really difficult
unstructured immature market and people
are giving us a hard time over saying
right we've decided not to prosecute
screen sniping cases and and all i want
to say is well look
i don't i would love to prosecute that
it's not it's not you know for
a person interested in sports integrity
the last thing on earth you want to be
doing
is knowing people are cheating and not
not doing something about it
but at the same time we're in the real
world and they're
you know putting it bluntly there are
bigger problems than guys watching a
delayed stream
and you know at best getting a bit of
information about economy
at the end there smith is referring to
some larger scale even
more potentially damaging investigations
that esic
is currently grappling with and that's
where we currently stand when it comes
to stream sniping and online cs go
for now as far as tos and esic are
concerned
no past offenses will be prosecuted but
all
future offenses will be broadcast delays
of three minutes or more will help
negate the advantages you would get from
ghosting
and betting services will change their
markets based on real-time events
and not on stream time with the next
major already canceled and with cs go
looking like it's going to be online
only for a while to come
we can only hope that these measures and
this warning will be enough to stop
any further stream sniping abuse
okay we're done just need an m board i
didn't
i didn't have a specific idea for an m
board on this one
energy
oh yeah
gotta channel my macho man randy savage
and become the cream of the crop on
youtube oh
yeah or maybe my hulk hogan listen
dear dude because when the hulkamania
slams you on that's becoming just randy
savage doing a
hulk hogan impression i just destroyed
my throat